i know you've been waiting this morning
we have more from our morning's mixtape
conversation with the founder of the
classic motown group the temptations and
the great otis williams he shared with
us what it was like touring the south
back in 1964 during segregation he told
us about a powerful moment when the
group saw firsthand how the country was
changing
gail
we were on a tour in 1964.
we went to columbia south carolina
got to the auditorium now this is with
the classic five david eddie paul melvin
myself
when we got to the auditorium there was
a rope
right down the center of the auditorium
a rope a rope
black's on one side
white's on the other side that's what
the audience looked like back then wow
when we got there we said you got to be
kidding really
so the chimps we went out and did a
thing you know performed how did you
feel doing that
we had to concentrate on what we were
doing but we didn't feel happy about it
you know so when we came back the second
year same place
there was no rope down the center of the
auditorium
blacks and whites sitting side by side
high fiving enjoying the music and booty
banging and uh yeah
if it wasn't for the uh sweat that we
were perspiring you know because it was
hot
they would have seen five guys on stage
crying
this past february we were in atlanta
and derrick my road manager said oh this
is a man out here would like to talk to
you i said okay let me finish getting
dressed i came out and
we shook hands he said mr williams
i am
the little boy
that put that rope down the center of
the auditorium
he said i wasn't raised that way but
they made me do it but i had to come and
tell you this was a white man yes wow
and i'm standing there like
you know
wow so when you see the audience
together and they're all dancing
together that brought tears to your eyes
oh i still do yeah music can be like a
wonderful common denominator and i've
seen people get together didn't care
about the skin color they were having
fun that's the power of music
i was fascinated by that story guys
because oda said all these years he's
always wondered who put that rope there
i go that's what you thought about
because yeah because i was so deeply
affected by that so for the man to come
to him years later and apologize and say
i'm so sorry it wasn't they made me do
it was very touching to him isn't that a
perfect example of how
hate segregation is taught yes he said
as a little boy i didn't want to exactly
years later because it was still on his
heart exactly you had to say it yes like
that's powerful and that and that i
don't mean to cut you off tony but a
parent parents that are out there
teaching kids hate racism ideology like
you are feeding into something that they
don't naturally have people are born
with love right you have to teach hate
yeah but there's another layer of
complexity which is he's the the kid
said he wasn't raised that way exactly
they made him do it that's a bigger
cultural issue right exactly right that
venue made him do it well unity made him
do it and that years later he's still
affected by it nate i missed you
yesterday because i wanted you to check
out otis outfit oh i was clean
oh this is clean
oh this is very clean and otis is still
on the road performing just like they
always say one temptation always that's
what he said